le départ a été précipitée les combats
sont désormais loin en pologne l'autobus
peut s'arrêter à bord surtout des femmes
et des enfants les hommes âgés de 18 à
60 ans doivent se battre le père de
maria n'a donc pas pu l'accompagner sa
mère est aussi resté en ukraine
un voyage de 24 heures dont sept passés
à la douane maintenant dans l'union
européenne les réfugiés sont en sécurité
sans savoir quand ils retrouveront leurs
pays et leurs proches
mes parents pourraient mourir dans un ou
deux mois c'est la pire chose au non dit
elle depuis le début de l'invasion russe
50000 ukrainiens auraient déjà quitté le
pays selon l'onu la crise pourrait
causer le déplacement de jusqu'à 5
millions de réfugiés les pays membres de
l'union européenne promet de les aider
nous le ferons en européen de manière
coordonnée responsable et solidaire des
représentants des 27 pays membres de
l'union européenne vont se rencontrer au
cours de la fin de semaine pour tenter
d'établir une stratégie commune dans le
but d'accueillir les réfugiés d'ici là
les ukrainiens qui quittent leur pays
peuvent compter sur la générosité des
polonais près du poste frontalier de
nombreux conducteurs attendent
patiemment des passagers
c'est le cas de cet homme venu de
varsovie est prête à offrir transport
jusqu'à la capitale
d'autres comme ce polonais temps à leur
manière d'aider les ukrainiens rester
derrière ils à acheter de l'équipement
de premiers soins bien nécessaire de
l'autre côté de la frontière
ce sont nos voisins nos amis nous avons
une histoire commune lance-t-il ici de
nombreux ukrainiens cherchent à entrer
dans l'union européenne
certains font le choix de retourner dans
un pays en plein conflit cet ukrainien
qui travaillent du côté polonais qui est
allé défendre son pays
la passion
n'est ce pas cet homme qui est également
soldats ira rejoindre les combats
marie a désormais en pologne mènera lieu
de différentes rappeler au monde que
l'ukraine a besoin des deux
mais pour l'instant c'est bien la guerre
qui chamboule des millions de vies ici
rafale bouvier auclair radio-canada
adorent aux cas la frontière entre la
pologne et l'ukraine